retour en france un collège de
montpellier est occupé depuis le début
de la semaine par des parents d'élèves
des parents qui protestent contre le
manque de personnel de surveillance et
contre le climat de violence auxquels
sont soumis leurs enfants le reportage
sur place de jacques baril face à des
manifestations de violence et
d'insécurité à l'intérieur de ses murs
et manque cruellement de moyens en
personnels susceptibles d'enrayer le
phénomène la lettre d'encouragement d'un
parlementaire c'est le soutien reçus ce
matin par des parents du collège des
aiguerelles à montpellier depuis hier
ses parents se relaient pour fermer
l'entrée du collège
ils prennent ainsi le relais des
enseignants en grève depuis le 6 janvier
à la suite de l'agression d'une
surveillante par des élèves nullement de
surveillants le manque de personnel
ils sont livrés à eux mêmes donc c'est
un petit peu la loi du plus fort
on a plein de problèmes qui surgissent
dans tous les coins de l'établissement
et n'y a jamais un adulte là à temps
pour arrêter tout ça je pense qu'on va
la perte des écoles publiques moi ça me
rend malade et de savoir qu'il faut la
sauver et on il faut donner les moyens
l'éducation nationale à l'éducation en
général dans cet établissement de 760
élèves le découragement et sensible
parents et enseignants réclament une
infirmière une assistante sociale du
personnel d'entretien et surtout des
postes d'encadrement et tandis que les
parents occupent collège les enseignants
se réunissent de leur côté à la maison
pour tous ouazine il faut il faut venir
des enseignants apprécient la solidarité
des parents leur inquiétude est
manifeste
est ce qu'on ne veut surtout pas c'est
attendre que la violence se manifeste
par une mort par un accident énorme
avant de réagir
je crois qu'on ne veut pas attendre les
l'incident grave qui nous fera réagir et
nous mettent en grève
quatre surveillants supplémentaires
peuvent-ils dompter la violence
quotidienne quand les 70 enseignants
surveillants actuels ne suffisent pas la
solution ne semble pas simple en tout
cas jeudi une délégation ira à paris
présenter des revendications au ministre